morning a protest is planned at the Las
Vegas Convention Center it is being led
by Southwest Airlines flight attendants
frustrated by the company's slow
response to that holiday travel meltdown
Lauren negretti is live this morning at
the convention center with the story
Lauren good morning to you
that's right good morning John yes that
picket kicks off at about noon like you
said outside this Las Vegas Convention
Center with me I have the union
president Lynn Montgomery Lynn share
with us the overall demands for change
you guys are having here the first big
change is modernization we haven't had
modernization changes to our contract
basically since 2009 but our operation
has changed dramatically so the union
has been asking for a long time for the
company to invest in its I.T technology
and also its winter weather
methodology how they handle the winter
weather and also ensuring that flight
attendants are compensated flight tents
are really suffering right now with
inflation they're working harder they're
having to work more for Less so that's
very important that we see contractual
races okay great you guys are going to
be here for those couple hours just
before this uh the the rally the rally
2023 kicks off that is the Southwest
employee designated event yeah yeah and
we don't feel like celebrating we need
the company to know that it's time they
make it right
thank you so so much and we did reach
out for we did reach out to Southwest
for a comment that comment is on your
screen there that they respect their
employees and allow them to express
their opinions in a cordial manner
negotiations uh go on through next week
and through the month of March for now
live in Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News
Now